don't hit me stop time out let me figure
out the buttons first I'm not going to
hit you just let me
okay oh I forgot the buttons now wait a
second that was yeah I'm not gonna hit
you nice all right I feel I feel good
now I'm the blue guy right you are the
blue guy are you ready to go yeah okay
all right
what why why am I winning
oh my gosh I'm winning
guys no one expected okay wait stop stop
time out time out time out
just wait one second
I just want to talk to you
okay how do I how do I do my magical uh
ice powers I don't know if I should tell
you that considering how the round's
going
what's going on Mr Walsh
oh oh there it is ow there it is
pencil here that is just
look at that
um